INSULTING YOU.
>> BOTH OF US, ACTUALLY.
>> I LIKE TO THINK OF JUST YOU.
>> RIGHT, OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
>> JOINING US LIVE FROM THE
ATLANTIS PARADISE ISLAND IN THE
BAHAMAS WHERE HE'LL BE DEEJAYING
MOMENTS FROM NOW, NICK CANNON IS
JOINING US.
>> HEY, NICK, HOW YOU DOING?
>> LOVE, MY BROTHERS, IT'S ALL
LOVE OUT HERE.
>> WOW.
>> THANK YOU.
I CAN'T SEE YOU BUT I'M SURE YOU
LOOK GREAT AS WELL.
>> WE LOOK OKAY.
WE LOOK LIKE WET SPONGES.
NICK, LAST TIME -- LAST THING I
HEARD ABOUT YOU, YOU HAD JUST
RECOVERED FROM PNEUMONIA.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
ARE YOU OKAY?
>> OH, MAN, I'M DOING A LOT
BETTER.
MY CONDITION AND EVERYTHING,
LUPUS, IT TAKES LONGER TO GET
BETTER THAN NORMAL.
I'M SURROUNDED BY GOD AND ENERGY
HERE IN PARADISE AND BRINGING IN
THE NEW YEAR THE RIGHT WAY.
I'M FEELING AMAZING RIGHT NOW.
>> AWESOME.
YOU ORIGINALLY WELCOMED YOUR
12th CHILD, A DAUGHTER, HALO
MARIE CANNON.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HOW IS EVERYONE DOING?
>> THANK YOU, MAN.
THE FAMILY IS AMAZING.
EVERYBODY'S HEALTHY.
THAT'S ALL WE COULD ASK FOR.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
NICK, YOU ARE SINGLE-HANDEDLY
REPOPULATING THE EARTH.
I GIVE IT UP TO YOU, MAN.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN HERE?
WHAT IS YOUR END GAME WITH THE
KIDS?
YOU JUST WANT TO KEEP GOING?
OR IS THERE A NUMBER?
DO YOU WANT TO HIT 20?
WHERE ARE WE GOING WITH THIS?
>> CLEARLY, I DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
HONESTLY, IT'S REALLY JUST SO
MUCH JOY AND ELATION THAT I
HAVE, THE FAMILY I HAVE, I
EMBRACE IT, I LOVE IT.
BUT I DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEAR FROM
THE JUMP.
>> A VASECTOMY?
>> IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT ME TO
GET?
THIS IS MY BODY, MY CHOICE.
>> YES, YES.
THAT IS RIGHT.
GOOD FOR YOU, GOOD ANSWER.
>> NICK, DO YOU HAVE ANY NEW
YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS?
>> I DON'T MAKE RESOLUTIONS.
I'M JUST SO HAPPY FOR HEALTH AND
WANT TO CONTINUE TO BE AS
HEALTHY AND FILLED WITH AS MUCH
GRATITUDE AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
NEXT YEAR.
>> BY THE WAY, GIVEN THAT YOU DO
HAVE 12 KIDS, DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADVICE FOR NEW FATHERS OUT
THERE?
>> I MEAN, JUST OPERATE OUT OF
LOVE.
SOME PEOPLE MAY SAY THAT GOT US
HERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD ALWAYS DO.
ALWAYS DO IT WITH A SMILE.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
HOW WERE THE HOLIDAYS?
WERE YOU WITH ALL THE KIDS?
OR -- HOW WAS IT?
>> I WAS ST. NICK, TRAVELING ON
MY SLEIGH THROUGHOUT THE NATION,
MAKING SURE ALL THE KID IS HAPPY
AND FULL OF HOLIDAY CHEER.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
THAT IS AWESOME.
YOU HAVE SO MANY JOBS.
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR PROFESSIONAL
HIGHLIGHT OF THE YEAR?
DO YOU HAVE ONE?
>> MAN, I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SO MANY THINGS.
THIS YEAR, FATHERHOOD.
I MEAN, THAT'S OBVIOUSLY MY
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
BUT WE STILL GOT EVERYTHING THAT
WE GOT GOING.
WE JUST WRAPPED SEASON 20.
WHICH IS MONUMENTAL THAT WE HAVE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
EPISODES OF SOMETHING I JUST
CREATED OUT OF MY MIND, YOU
KNOW, ALMOST 20 YEARS AGO.
SO "WHILE AND OUT" WAS PROBABLY
THE HIGHLIGHT FOR THIS YEAR.
>> I WANT TO -- YOU KNOW,
SPEAKING OF "WILD N' OUT" BEING
ON TV FOR 20 SEASONS, I WANT TO
PLAY A LITTLE GAME.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
WILDEST EXPERIENCE.
>> OH-OH.
>> YOU JUST TELL ME -- GIVE ME
YOUR ANSWERS.
TELL ME, WHO'S THE WILDEST
PERSON YOU'VE EVER PARTIED WITH?
>> THE WILDEST PERSON -- I
PARTIED WITH YOU BEFORE.
YOU WAS PRETTY TAME.
I HAVE TO SAY, HONESTLY -- YEAH,
YEAH, RIGHT -- I HAVE TO SAY --
MAN.
KEVIN HART.
DEFINITELY KEVIN HART.
>> OH, REALLY?
HE'LL BE HERE.
>> HE'S JOINING US LATER, WE'LL
TALK TO HIM ABOUT THAT, SEE WHAT
HE SAYS.
>> THAT IS EXCELLENT.
>> YEAH, ASK HIM ABOUT 2006.
YEAH, ASK HIM ABOUT THAT YEAR.
>> OH, REALLY?
2006.
THAT BROAD.
>> OKAY.
>> WHERE'S THE WILDEST --
>> HE'LL KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> REALLY?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> SOMETHING HAPPENED IN 2006
WITH NICK CANNON?
ALL RIGHT.
>> LOVE IT.
>> WHAT'S BEEN THE WILDEST PLACE
YOU'VE EVER CELEBRATED NEW
YEAR'S EVE?
>> I MEAN, THIS IS PRETTY
AMAZING OUT HERE IN PARADISE IN
THE BAHAMAS.
YEAH, I'M GOING TO GO WITH THAT,
GIVE YOU THAT ONE.
THIS IS ECSTASY OUT HERE.
>> WHERE'S THE WILDEST PLACE YOU
FOUND OUT YOU WERE GOING TO BE A
FATHER?
>> CHURCH.
>> WOW.
>> AT CHURCH.
>> WOW, OKAY, WOW.
>> CONVENIENT.
>> YES.
>> WHERE'S THE WILDEST PLACE
YOU'VE EVER GOTTEN WILD?
IF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> THE WHAT?
WOULD I BE BAD, CHURCH AGAIN?
>> WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE IT
THERE.
>> YEAH, HOW DO YOU -- WHERE DO
YOU GO FROM THERE?
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
NICK, LOVE SEEING YOU.
YOU LOOK GREAT IN WHITE.
>> YO.
>> I WANT YOU TO HAVE A GREAT
DEEJAY SET TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HAVE FUN DOWN THE